my friend ian rappaport
who joins us right now on the rich eisen
show how are you ian
uh i have no idea
i don't know i have no idea you have no
idea how you are or what's going on with
randy i know what's going on there's a
lot of things going on randy gregory is
uh
you know i guess making the decision i
guess this is where it is now i mean it
sounds like
you know i i had i know one team was in
it very heavy for him that bowed out
because they
saw emotionally what it was doing to him
you know what i mean like this was huh
this was a tough decision and
you know it felt like he was going back
to the cowboys then his agent peter
shafer was on the record
you know discussing why he was going to
the cowboys
and uh then he decided not to go to the
cowboys and the broncos flipped them and
we'll see if this is the last flip-flop
of the day oh that's a good point or
from him or just anybody
could be i mean from him but also could
be anyone
wow how about that
back here on the rich eisen show
terrestrial radio show ian rappaport
joining me here on the rich eisen show
uh to our terrestrial audience we say
hello to him for a second time all right
ian what is the um what does the
contract from aaron rodgers tell you
about the commitment aaron rodgers and
the packers have made to one another
ian
uh so the
uh
the contract is very interesting right
uh so basically what it is is 50 million
dollars per year over the first three
years of the deal it is 62 million
dollars per year over the first two
years of the deal and there's 150
million dollars guaranteed that's the
nuts and bolts of it that's kind of the
important part
it feels to me based on the language
based on the numbers that is a two-year
commitment from aaron rodgers and from
what i understood if he was going to go
to say the broncos he was going to
commit to them for two years so it makes
sense
um
it makes sense that if he was going to
go back to the packers he would do it
for two years could also potentially be
for three years so
you know we're not going to be doing
this again for aaron rodgers next year
we at least have two years before we
have to do the exact same thing again
which is good because
i
i don't know if i can do this again
i think you got it in you ian i think
you got it in you so so the the whole
idea of the out that he negotiated last
year
um as a backstop
um
from being franchise tagged in a spot he
doesn't want to be in anymore
um
is that gone is that out of the contract
now that's that that's part of the
reason why it's a two-year deal do you
think uh so
that was never in the contract actually
and it was sort of reported that it was
but it actually wasn't that was more of
a friendship
hand
shake agreement
um
that if it didn't get to a point where
he wanted that they would kind of look
at a trade but i i have not heard
anything about that now i mean it seems
like
aaron rodgers going to retire remember
the green bay packers barring some sort
of like dramatic turn that i can't even
perceive like i think
at the end of all this aaron rodgers has
signed his last contract with the
packers will retire a packer
and everything that green bay did
relationship wise to keep him in the
fold
was worth it and was noted um and
honestly was pretty incredible so what
does this mean for devonte adams now
that you've seen
the numbers for uh rogers
we think uh
you know i would say it's still
difficult to get a deal done and i guess
anything is possible but
um it's hard it's hard to get a deal
done i know that they're at a point now
with the money where i don't know where
it goes honestly um
he has not
they are nowhere on the negotiations i
know that they offered him a big deal
but
um
you know it was not it was not highest
paid
um receiver in the nfl money it was not
more than deandre hopkins it was not
where
he needed to be so he has not
is not engaged with them and you know
could they get a deal done i guess
anything is possible i don't see how and
he has told them that he is not going to
play
not going to play for the franchise play
so see what goes from here so that drama
plays out between now and july 15th
which is the deadline for which a
franchise tag player can get a long-term
contract from the team that's put the
tag on him correct
yeah yes so and you know i don't expect
him any anywhere near the packers until
then uh maybe
so then maybe you know i mean again like
it's it's a hard deal to do
you would think if they were gonna do it
it would have happened already
um
but i you know i don't know i've seen
i've seen things turn around quickly
we'll see if that could happen here but
i just don't i really don't sense it so
you know at some point the situation has
to come to a head and we'll see where it
goes and i think what you told me
yesterday on nfl network i imagine that
still stands is the the hold up is the
argument over
what what
is
the the uh
who is the highest paid receiver and
what what is the the money in deandre
hopkins contract really saying
right towards that argument correct
right because you know agents say well
all contract extensions are based on new
money that's true
but then you see this one and people go
well yeah but that's not i mean that's
not really based on your money that's
you know two years that's 27 million
dollars a year it's tacked on to the end
of the deal it's added spread it out
through five years like if they don't
people don't consider it real
the players do and devonta adams does so
that's why there is
you know
i i don't know where it goes but there's
certainly an impasse here a few more
minutes left here with ian rap report
from nfl network here on a very busy
free agent tuesday in the nfl what's
going on with desean watson best you can
tell yeah
so dusan watson is meeting with the
cleveland browns today their brass is
flying down to meet him in person in
houston the atlanta falcons need to come
tomorrow
um
you know is it a long shot probably um
but we'll see they're going to take you
know they're going to take their shot i
would say
and then he met with the new orleans
saints and the carolina panthers
yesterday and you know it seems to me
that the saints are in good position um
we'll see what his meetings with the
browns and and falcons are like we'll
see if there's a surprise team in there
as well so when you say the browns are
in does that mean mayfield's part of a
deal what can you tell me about
compensation from your sense uh that
nick casario is going to want
from that team in particular um i have
not 100 confirmed that mayfield would be
in the deal
um
i think he might be but i have not
confirmed that he will be uh he doesn't
have to be
you know i mean what you could do is you
could
you know basically just trade for sean
watson and then
say to the colts or seattle like all
right like give us a one or
you know i don't know whatever it would
be for baker maple so it's not like he
has to be in the trade right you would
be able to trade him somewhere so and
i'm of course clearly that would be the
case with matt ryan right if the falcons
land
desean watson uh yeah i mean i i would
imagine that
matt ryan would then
you know go to the cults or the seahawks
would be my guess
does that affect what's going on with
jimmy g like the colts would basically
say hey you know hey san francisco lower
your price for jimmy g we'll take him
off your hands now because when watson
goes somewhere else
you know um that might leave seattle's
the only one left at the table who needs
a quarterback and you're not trading
them there right so you might as well
trade them here something like that
being a foot
do you think well yeah but i think also
um
you know the the colts have done this
with the quarterback coming back from
the shoulder remember andrew luck was
coming back from the shoulder and was
supposed to be ready then it wasn't
ready and then there was a setback and
there's
you know
it was just there was a lot and i don't
know that they want to do that again i
mean they looked into it there were
trade talks all that and they still
might do it they still could revisit it
i just haven't sensed that
it's anything imminent you know so
i think we might be talking about this
right before the draft while we're all
hanging out in vegas um maybe by then
they'll have a better idea of where his
shoulder is
he still won't be throwing but maybe
we'll know a little more
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here